hey this is presh talwalkar
a circle with radius one is tangent to
two points of the parabola y equals x
squared
what is the area between the circle and
the parabola
here's a diagram to illustrate the
problem we have the parabola y equals x
squared and then we have a circle of
radius one that's tangent to the
parabola at two points
the question is what's the area that's
highlighted in red in between the circle
and the parabola
i want to thank chad fatiolo for sending
me this puzzle
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
i'll proceed to find the answer in a
series of three steps
we'll first determine the center of the
circle
then we'll find the intersection points
between the circle and the parabola
we'll then calculate the area in two
different ways
we'll first find the area using addition
and subtraction of simple shapes
we'll then also solve it using an
integral
so let's proceed by finding the center
of the circle
you can experiment with where the circle
could be
once you try and figure out where the
circle could be
you'll come to the conclusion the circle
has to be in a particular position
to be tangent at two points the circle
has to be above the parabola
its center also has to be on the line x
equals 0 which means the center of the
circle has to be a point of the form
0 comma b
so what's the value of b
the circle's radius of 1 has to be the
minimal distance from the center of the
circle to the parabola
so we can attempt to solve for b by
solving a minimization problem
we'll minimize the distance between the
center of the circle
to the parabola a point on the parabola
y equals x squared will have a form x
comma x squared
using the distance formula we want to
minimize the following function
but before we do that we can use a
little trick
since distance is not negative it will
be easier to minimize the distance
squared
this will allow us to get rid of the
square root
so it'll be easier for us to take the
derivative and find the correct value of
b
so let's do this
we'll find the critical values by
solving for where the derivative equals
0.
we end up with the following equation
we then factor out 2x and we need to
solve this equation
for where x leads it to be equal to zero
there are two possibilities
one is that two x could equal zero
this would mean x would equal zero
we now take this value and substitute it
back into our distance squared function
this means the distance squared will be
equal to b squared
and notice the distance from the center
of the circle
to the parabola which will be also on
the circle
this has to be equal to the radius
squared of the circle and we know the
circle has a radius of one so this means
b squared has to be equal to one
this leads to two possible values b
equals plus one or b equals minus one
could these be the possible center of
the circle
no
a circle centered at either zero one or
zero negative one will not be tangent at
two points of the parabola
we can see this geometrically
a circle centered at zero negative one
will be tangent only at the origin
and then a circle centered at zero one
will be tangent also at the origin but
it will also touch the parabola at two
other points one one and negative one
one
so these are not possible solutions for
a circle being tangent to the parabola
at exactly two points
so we then consider the other
possibility
what if one plus two times the quantity
x squared minus b equals zero
we can solve this equation to get that x
squared equals b minus one half
once again we substitute into the
distance squared function
and this leads to the equation that the
distance squared is equal to b minus one
4 which equals the radius squared which
equals 1.
therefore
b is equal to 5 4.
when we tried that it turns out to be a
sensible solution and this in fact is
the center of the circle
now we need to find the intersection
points between the circle and the
parabola
we have a circle of radius one that's
centered at zero comma by fourths
this circle will have an equation
x squared plus the quantity y minus five
fourths squared
equals 1.
where will this intersect the parabola
where y equals x squared
we can solve this system of equations
we'll substitute in y equals x squared
into the first equation
so we have y plus the quantity y minus 5
4 squared is equal to 1.
after a little bit of simplification
we get that y minus 3 4 the quantity
squared is equal to zero
and therefore y is equal to
three-fourths
y equals x squared so we get that x is
equal to negative square root of three
over two or x is equal to positive
square root of three over two
so we found our two intersection points
we now need to solve for the area
so let's set up a little bit of diagram
using our values of the intersection
points
the red area can be found by addition
and subtraction of a few simple shapes
we'll set up that the red area is equal
to the area of this entire rectangle
minus the portions which do not belong
to the red area
so we'll subtract the area underneath
the parabola
and then we need to subtract the area
that's above the circle
this will be a circular segment
so what's the area of this circular
segment well we need to solve for it
using the areas of shapes that we can
calculate easily
so this circular segment can be
calculated as follows
we take the circular sector
originating from the center of the
circle
and then we'll subtract out this
isosceles triangle
from the circular sector
so this circular segment is equal to the
area of the circular sector minus the
area of this triangle
so we'll substitute that in for the
circular segment and now we can simplify
that a red area is equal to the area of
the rectangle minus the area under the
parabola minus the area of the circular
sector plus the area of this triangle
so let's calculate for the area of each
of these shapes
the rectangle has a length of square
root of three and a height of
three-fourths so its area will be
three-fourths the square root of three
the area under the parabola can be found
using the integral of x-squared from
negative square root of 3 over 2 to
positive square root of 3 over 2.
this is standard calculation
we end up with square root of 3 over 4.
now the area of the circular sector and
the triangle will will require a little
bit of geometry
so let's draw this triangle again
we know that its
radius is equal to 1 because that's the
radius of the circle
so that's one length of the triangle
what are the other lengths
well the height will be five-fourths
minus three-fourths so that's one-half
finally the base will have two segments
of square root of three over two
now look at the lengths of this triangle
we have a triangle with lengths square
root of three over two one half and one
this is the lengths of a special
triangle
each half of this triangle is a 30 60
30-60-90 right triangle
or in radians the angles are pi over 6
pi over 3 and pi over 2.
so we know that this particular angle is
pi over 3 or 60 degrees and this angle
is also the same so now we know the
central angle of this sector
the central angle
is two pi over three
this circular sector has a radius of one
and the area of the circular sector is
one half times r squared theta
we substitute in our values and we get
the area of the circular sector is pi
over 3.
now we solve for the area of this
triangle it is a base of square root of
three and a height of one half
we use the formula for the area of a
triangle and substitute in these values
to get this area a square root of three
over four
so now we calculate the area of the red
segment using what we just calculated
we can cancel out the area under the
parabola with the area of the triangle
it actually turns out those are both
equal to the same value it's kind of an
interesting little piece of trivia
so now we have the area of this red
segment is equal to 3 4 square root of 3
minus pi over 3
and that's approximately equal to 0.2518
and that's our answer
so this is one way to approach the
problem but we could have also
approached it using an integral
remember the circle is given by the
following
equation we'll now solve for the lower
half of this circle by taking the
negative square root of that equation so
the lower half of the circle is given by
the equation 5 4 minus the square root
of 1 minus x squared
we want to solve for the area between
this curve
and the parabola which is x squared so
we can set up a single integral which is
the difference between the lower half of
the circle and the parabola y equals x
squared and we compute that integral
between negative square root of 3 over 2
and positive square root of 3 over 2.
this will also give us the area
so how do we calculate this integral
we can break down into three different
terms
it'll be easier to calculate
some of these as separate integrals so
we'll break it off into three different
integrals
the first integral is straightforward to
calculate and the last integral is also
straightforward to calculate
so we have 10 square root of 3 over 8
minus 2 square root of 3 over 8 which
simplifies to be square root of 3.
so our ultimate answer will be square
root of 3 minus this one somewhat
complicated integral
so how can we evaluate this integral
this is a textbook example for using a
trig substitution
x equals sine theta
this means dx is equal to cosine theta d
theta
and if the x values go between negative
square root of 3 over 2 and positive
square root of 3 over 2
that means theta will go between
negative pi over 3 and positive pi over
3.
so we do this trig substitution
and now we can simplify this integral
we use some trigonometric identities
and then we end up with the integral of
the cosine squared of theta
this is also a standard thing to
evaluate
so we then evaluate this integral
and we end up that the answer is the
same as before 3 4 the square root of 3
minus pi over three
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions if you like this video you can
support me on patreon and you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description you can also catch me
on social media either at preshtalwalkar
or at mindyourdecisions
depending on the site